- Welcome to the all new GRIDIRON HEIGHTS SPORTSBOOK!
- [Voiceover:] GAMBLING! GAMBLING! IF YOU GAMBLE,
IT’S LIKE YOU’RE PLAYING TOO!
- We’re kicking it off with a special Wild Card Tournament.
- I FINALLY GET TO PLAY.
- I’m alive. I swear.
- [Voiceover:] USE PROMO CODE: F--KOFFORBET.
- This is my first time in a casino.
- Really?
- [Together:] Derek imposes a curfew.
- [Voiceover:] BET IN VEGAS, NOT ON VEGAS, IDIOT!
- WOW, MVP-CALIBER RAISE THERE, BRADY.
- Um, how much? Sorry, I didn’t quite catch that.
- [Voiceover:] CHECK OUT THE...
- [Kid Voiceover:] GRIDIRON HEIGHTS JR.
- [Voiceover:] GAMBLING CORNER.
- You see, kids, Jerry Jones is like Mr. Krabs
if he made his money from aggressive oil refining instead of burgers.
- [Voiceover:] DON’T LIKE A PARALYZING SUN GLARE IN AN INDOOR FACILITY?
PLAY OUTSIDE!
- But I went all in.
- [Voiceover:] OVER/UNDER HOW MANY TIMES WILL STAFFORD BLOW IT?
- Can everyone stop yelling at me?
- I told you, fam. We folded back in Week 14.
- Well, I bet—
- The game is over.
- WHAT?! OH, NO, I'M MELTING.
- [Al Michaels:] This team reminds me of the 2001 Patriots: They are no longer playing.
- Fun fact: No one has ever sent a text about a Burrow playoff loss.
- [Voiceover:] AND KEEP BETTING NEXT WEEK WHEN GREEN BAY TAKES ON THE NINERS.
- WELL, WHERE'S ALEX SMITH NOW?
- You know how when you’re bored of 'Rugrats' and just waiting for 'The Loud House' to come on?
That’s like Jimmy G and Trey Lance.
- A third down is like the Smurfs.
I will NOT elaborate.
- See a safety is like 'Rocket Power.'
What’s that? That’s not on anymore?
- Your loss, kids!